empowerment is an intrinsic motivation
that captures how much an agent is in
control of the world it can itself
perceive so an agent wants to be
empowered because it wants to have many
options that lead to different outcomes
choices that are actually meaningful and
affecting the world around it and as
such empowerment is intrinsically linked
to the agency of an agent to its sense
of self-preservation to the level of
causal efficacy it has in the world and
thereby it differs from these
arbitrarily assigned functions and
machine learning it is something that is
it's a kernel of the motivation of the
agent and not just some instrumental
goal but rather a basis that governs all
motivations and behavior of the agent
and can actually be used to create
specific sub goals for the agent itself